[Music]
hey everyone welcome to reboot episode
1.5 as it were I think that's how we're
going to roll with it right I think so I
think that's the plan if you haven't yet
this episode will not make sense go back
and watch the first episode of reboot
it's called resin evil 7 finishes what
Silent Hill started that was the first
episode of reboot go watch that for
those you don't know in the off week of
that biweekly show we're going to be
doing this just a very casual kind of
podcast style reflection on the last
episode teasing the next episode but
mainly in the most important part
getting feedback from people a lot of
which we have for the episode today this
here reboot 1.5 you know YouTube
comments tweets what you thought about
the first episode what you might want to
see in the next episode or a couple
episodes going forward Jake and I as the
two halves of reboot are really
interested in hearing your thoughts and
we're depending on you to help drive the
show most comes for positive there are a
couple people who like kind of had
little issues with it some there I don't
know just little things and then the
rest of the comments were people saying
you guys relaunching reboot get old like
the first animated cartoon ever it's
just polygamous green people I think a
Canadian show something like that I'll
pull that up right now you're kind of
looking at it right now as you can see
it's kind of creepy it always did lately
out when I took trivia um my friend just
the other day like brought it up but I'm
like can I forget how much that show
like was upsetting but believe it or not
we didn't call the show reboot because
of that show essentially just the idea
of when you finally get through games or
something or you want to kind of look at
games differently you know reboot how
you think I guess something along those
lines it spongy but also yeah a lot of
people mentioned it's got Danielle wire
flavor if you're a longtime GameSpot fan
or the point fan you probably noticed
this feels like the point and that's
where we got the inspiration when Danny
left we didn't really have that
editorial opinion show and now you know
obviously we've been watching his stuff
Jake and I for like years now and
they're not like trying to hide the fact
that we are taking a lot of inspiration
from Danny I think that would be I mean
both of us have watched his stuff for a
long time and I think it is a definite
inspiration but
you also are trying to put our own
flavour on it and I think this is kind
of how we're trying to do it with this
sort of 1.5 episode and plus like
obviously my opinions different from
Danny's Mike's opinion is different from
Danny's yes it follows a similar format
and we will be the first to admit that
but we're hoping we can do something a
little different and that might take a
little longer than we expect but we hope
we're headed down that direction now
anyway yeah so we do have comments
thanks so much for getting your comments
in YouTube like I said we'll feature you
will call you out whether you tweet at
us or you comment on the YouTube video
we're focusing on YouTube we do have the
video on site and we'll go through those
eventually but oddly enough we were
looking through and youtube of all
places was very positive reception yes
so the first one we're looking at is by
beau Viper on YouTube I think that's how
you pronounce it
Michael mihari I was surprised you left
out out last including the new one and
Bioshock when discussing survival horror
still an awesome video do you think the
rise of youtubers and streamers playing
games with tons of jump scares has
influenced how devs are shaping the
genre yeah so that was actually I think
the video was originally like 20 seconds
longer because we mentioned alien
isolation we mentioned outlast I think I
touched
I might have touched on Bioshock but I
think I'm something so I think I was
thinking more to horror games it became
this long section in the middle of this
boring section that we just talked about
way too many horror games and I just
wanted to condense it into like this
small part about Indies and we already
did a documentary series you should
watch it's called reviving Resident Evil
2 more and they explore how like Indies
kept horror alive when resonable decline
and we wanted to focus more on how was
continuing what Sound Hill started with
this Renaissance thing but yeah so we
were just kind of you know we had to
pick which horror titles we wanted to
mention an alien isolation and the evil
within and outlast we're all kind of
just we couldn't delve too deep in them
without the video getting kind of too
long and I think you did touch on
amnesia which kind of kicked off that's
sort of indie horror yeah so like I mean
obviously outlast it may or may not be a
product of amnesia but amnesia is kind
of the pivotal indie game that kind of
kicked off that indie horror Renaissance
yeah
and that's for bovine first question is
actually really good question do you
think the rise of youtubers and
streamers playing games with tons of
jump scares has influenced devs
I think so in some way I think well I
don't know how much it's influenced into
like how much it carries over into the
final design of their products but they
must be thinking about that when they're
making games like almost unless you're
making some sort of I don't know I can't
think of any kind of games you make
today where you don't have the YouTube
audience in mind rights like Let's Plays
are so prevalent now such ubiquitous
thing to stumble across on YouTube
poor devs must be like oh I can't wait
to see people playing through this and
then getting the jump scares and I don't
know I can't speak to whether it
actually makes them put more jump scares
in I actually like resin evil 7 because
of how little it leaned on jump scares I
thought I think res navel 7 is great
because it's really good about that
dread and that kind of just creepy
disturbing underlying like survival
tinged horror rather than the jump
scares but I'd be interested to talk to
horror devs about whether they're
shaping their games with a youtube
audience in mind that'd be interesting
again both viper thanks for your
question and everybody else look forward
to your thoughts in the next episode
this one's from Tony Zuniga I pronounced
that right Tony's gonna get eight from
YouTube he says one problem that occurs
in many survival horror games and other
horror media is the lack of a satisfying
ending or is best when fear comes from
the unknown but there's always a point
where discoveries are made in the
mystery fades away leaving us with a
better leaving us with a bitter
aftertaste do you feel there's a good
way to end a [ __ ] to end a horror
stories what horror games do you feel
have done endings right
yeah I agree I'd say it's weird though
like guillermo del toro he says like
what's his quote always show the monster
which i always was more afraid in horror
when i didn't know what the monster was
but he was a big fan obviously of
showing it but yeah there's some times
most resin evil games
I think resin evil games were always too
cheesy to really scare me it was the
game play the moment-to-moment gameplay
of knowing it's a zombie in this room
and knowing I have only one bullet left
that's what terrifies me and that's why
I like seven because the survival comes
back and that's what has tension to it
but I think good I really liked that
last and I really liked them Nisha and I
think it was scarier when I knew there
was a monster around the corner than
when I could see him coming at me
and I also like the mechanic and outlast
where you're sprinting away and you can
look over your shoulder and see them
chasing you that's terrifying that kind
of plays into that fear I used to have
like that phobia of running up like the
basement stairs another kid and
something was chasing me is that did you
have that well I didn't have a basement
but do you know what I'm talking about
just that feeling it's something behind
you but yeah I I think it's a good way
to end horror stories I do like the one
to kind of leave some mystery I don't
like horror stories to make sense at the
end I think we fear what we don't
understand and if we feel like we
understand it completely then that's a
racist some of the disturbing aspects
yeah it's read though right because if
you don't understand it fully then it
feels unfulfilled yeah so it's like it's
a really thin line you have to walk yeah
all right next one Grant Wilson on
Twitter says definitely like the style
of the shoot mirroring the VHS tapes
from Resident Evil 7 was a great idea
this actually came kind of naturally I
think Mike really want to do something
on Resident Evil and we were thinking
like all found-footage would be cool and
it was just kind of seemed like a
natural idea for this it took a long
time it took a very long time to get
that look down and to find spots that
were scary and actually someone does ask
Riley
Rhino Riley I think this was Ryan
O'Reily ask where were these video
segments shot and they were shot in a
hotel one of our friends hotels basement
yeah and then actually in creepy place
yeah and then actually in our garage
yeah which we live with how creepy it is
yeah at the time of the shoot I lived
with Jake and uh our garage it looked
like there's mold growing on the walls
so like the last two camera shots that
you see the one where I turn out the
light bald and the one where I'm walking
down this hallway toward him that's our
basement Oh flash Garage Jake found like
eight layers for the filter that made it
look that way and then done yeah like
Jake said the rest came naturally just a
muffled audio and mica camera segments
the static shocks all out of nowhere the
rewind we're going to try to do that as
often as possible this series like when
it makes sense try to aim for an
aesthetic that fits what we're talking
about I think this was like the perfect
way to kick that off her breasts of the
wild Mike's can get electrocuted by
lightning on it yesyes our next episode
we'll get to it Oh
did i'll get electric it yeah we're a
green tunic and we could shoot in the
woods or something we're jumping the gun
on this one Kings Ellis on YouTube says
this is fantastic work not long but not
too long but informative and concise as
to what you guys should do next I think
you should do it Legend of Zelda reboot
is a no brainer I can't read with the
release of breath of the wild and how
much how much that title changes the
franchise it would make for a great
episode looking forward to more of these
I'm going to make this bigger okay well
I kind of spoil things ello is that
going to go as it happens yeah I'm in
the middle of so again we do have a few
episodes ready to go but a week from
today will our episode will be about
Zelda breath of the wild and Zelda in
general and I don't want too much about
the specifics but in order to tease it
yeah we're going to kind of look at
Zelda's influence on modern games and
how ubiquitous it really is and how we
seldom realize how much of an impact
Ocarina and the original Zelda had on
games at large but also how breath is
wild I think is a pretty important game
in the series I think that's about all
of the questions and comments I found
there weren't a lot of questions to be
honest it was mostly comments which is
cool but it's easier for us to respond
to questions rather than comments but
still those of you that did contribute
even those of you who just left in the
comments like great work that does mean
a lot especially something like this
which since it's not sponsored it is
entirely dependent on you guys so if you
guys liked it if you guys watch if you
guys share it then we can keep doing
stuff like this yeah we really want to
keep going with it and keep the
bi-weekly schedule going and again we
already have things planned and ready to
publish but we do need your input
because this is actually the what you're
watching now is what sets this show
apart from like things like Daniels wire
used to do that's a huge inspiration on
us but we we want to kind of do our own
thing as well and we want to have your
input and start a conversation like I
mentioned and we really appreciate you
sending in your thoughts on Twitter on
YouTube and keep doing so and we are
really excited to keep going forward
with reboot we're off to a good start we
a bit about it and we're so glad that
you guys all joined us so we'll see you
next week with its Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild
[Music]